When I lectured on Monday
about Marcus Garvey and a
little bit about
Father Divine,
what I was trying to get
at--towards the end was the
complicated texture of, for
the lack of a better phrase,
of-- pardon me. You know,
one should always remember
to turn one's
cell phone off,
especially if you're giving
the lecture. One thing I
wanted to get at was the
complicated texture of that
moment as far as the
position and ideology of
these important
black leaders,
their competing
philosophies,
where their
philosophies overlap,
and then the maybe sometimes
unpredictable ways that
their followers might
embrace all or parts of--of
their political, ideological
agenda. There is no single
leader for this moment that
I'm talking about for today,
which is, you know,
loosely called the Harlem
Renaissance. Now I'll--I'll
unpack that later on.
But it's certainly an era
and a moment filled with all
kinds of conflicting and
competing narratives. And
one of my goals--really my
main goal today is to sort
of begin to add texture to
the Harlem Renaissance and
add some complicating
narratives that I think get
us closer to the truth as
it was experienced on the
ground. To help us
in that direction,
I'm going to start with a
poem. It's actually a very
long poem, I'm only--and I'm
only going to read a short
part of it. And there's
many different versions of
the poem. But what
I'll be--the parts I'll be
reading from are really
sort of the most common
overlapping stanzas, as it
were. It's a poem by the
writer Cull--Countee
Cullen. Let me just launch
right into it.
"What is Africa to me:
Copper sun or scarlet sea,
Jungle star or jungle track,
Strong bronzed men, or regal
black Women from whose loins
I sprang, When the
birds of Eden sang?
One three centuries removed
From the scenes his
fathers loved, Spicy
grove, cinnamon tree,
What is Africa to me?"
This last line here is
often thought of as,
you know, "what
is Africa to me?"
the question. It's thought
of as the title of the
poem. It's not the title of
the poem. The title's much
more complicated, as we'll
see in a moment. Cullen
continues in the
poem: "Africa?
A book one
thumbs, Listlessly,
till slumber comes."
He then launches into an
extended exploration of the
naturalism of the African
scene that defined to him
what Africa was. You know,
you would have
herds of animals,
you know, flowing
through the savannah,
while, you know,
strong, black,
beautiful couples were
coupling in the--in the
savannah. They
were in their element,
a place of animals. Africa,
as you see in Cullen's poem,
was not a place that he had
any personal knowledge of,
but it's a place
that is, quote,
"a book one thumbs." It's
a place that you discover
through someone
else's words,
through someone else's
interpret--interpretation,
through knowledge that's
passed down. And in this
way, Africa is a
place of heritage,
and that's the
actual name of the poem,
it's called Heritage.
Continuing along in the
poem, after going through
these sort of naturalistic,
animalistic, exotic
scenes, Cullen continues,
"Quaint, outlandish heathen
gods Black men fashion out of
rods, Clay, and
brittle bits of stone,
In a likeness
like their own,
My conversion
came high-priced;
I belong to
Jesus Christ,
Preacher of
humility;
Heathen gods are
naught to me.
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost,
So I make an idle boast;
Jesus of the
twice-turned cheek,
Lamb of God, although I speak
With my mouth thus,
in my heart Do I play a double
part. Ever at Thy glowing altar
Must my heart grow
sick and falter,
Wishing He I
served were black,
Thinking then it would not lack
Precedent of pain to guide it,
Let who would or
might deride it;
Surely then this flesh would
know Yours had bone--
kindred woe. Lord, I
fashion dark gods, too,
Daring even to give You
Dark despairing features where,
Crowned with dark
rebellious hair,
Patience wavers just so much
as Mortal grief compels,
while touches
Quick and hot, of anger,
rise To smitten cheek
and weary eyes.
Lord, forgive me if my need
Sometimes shapes a
human creed. All day long
and all night through,
One thing only must I do:
Quench my pride and cool
my blood, Lest I
perish in the flood.
Lest a hidden ember set
Timber that I thought was wet
Burning like the driest flax,
Melting like the merest wax,
Lest the grave restore its dead.
Not yet has my heart or head
In the least way realized
They and I are civilized."
And now I know I gave you
like four or five stanzas
really quickly here.
There's--A few things that I
hope that you are hearing
in this reading. Cullen
wrestling with the
cost of conversion,
religious conversion, a
complicated recognition of
civilization, and the very
conscious evocation of race
pride. Cullen writes, "My
conversion came high-priced;
I belong to Jesus Christ."
It's his own recognition,
I think, that even when
though--even though he's
trained in the technique of
high European arts--this is
a very formalized
poem after all,
formalistic--the
"blessing," in quotes,
of training in civilization
came at a high price.
I mean, through
this poem the,
the--you see the, the, the
narrator talking about this
Africa he doesn't know,
landing in this naturalized,
exotic setting, and then
wrestling with what he sees
as religion, thinking,
"Oh, well this is really
backwards," and
thinking, "Well,
maybe it's actually
something different. Maybe
I can't actually see it
because of the way I've been
trained." And that
"it" he's talking about is
civilization. Cullen
acknowledged--or the
narrator acknowledges,
as the poem goes forward,
that Africans were
civilized. Throughout the
poem--I mean, by
the end of the poem,
you realize that throughout
the poem he's wrestling with
the question,
"Well, you know,
I know I'm civilized. I've
been converted. I belong to
Jesus Christ."
But, you know,
these--these
dark--these, these,
these
rods--these, these gods,
excuse me, they're
fashioning out of "dark and
brittle rods," maybe there's
something to that as well.
And what he's
really bemoaning,
I think, is the fact
that it took him so long to
understand that these
Africanist belief systems,
this fashioning of many
different kinds of dark
gods, that he actually saw
something desirable in it as
well; that he
often wished his god,
something you can't see and
can't hear in the reading of
it, but you see
in the print,
with, you know, he's
capitalizing "He" and "You"
often, that he wishes his
god were a god that looked
black, or looked, you know,
black African. And so it's
the pain of discovery that
he has lost something in the
process of gaining
something. He wished that,
quote, "He I served were
black" and that if there
were a black god, if
one could imagine it,
one could extend a belief
system such that there'd be
recognized--a recognition in
the United States that black
Americans might have
some purchase--a different
interpretation, certainly,
but a purchase--on one of
those most treasured
things of being civilized,
a formalized
religious belief system,
that a white god could be
a black god and still be a
god. It's a
powerfully complex poem,
speaks to all these
different issues: verbalized
pride in the natural
beauty and bounty of Africa,
at the same time speaking
ashamedly of its simplicity;
illuminating as it does that
heritage is something of
which one can be proud, but
also something about which
one can feel exquisite
pain. And the speaker
clearly feels, by
the end of the poem,
remorse about being torn
in these two different
directions.
Toward the end of the
poem, he asks forgiveness,
after all, for the actions
he takes that he feels are
necessitated by the strange
cruelties and ironies of
heritage. He says,
"Lord, forgive me if my need
sometimes shapes a human
creed." This last phrase,
"Lord, forgive me if my need
sometimes shapes a human
creed," really is a metaphor
that I want to use. I want
to use it as a metaphor,
deploy it if you will,
to help us get a purchase on
the New Negro Renaissance.
And one quick caveat
here--and I've already--in
fact, I've already done
it--I'll talk about the
Harlem Renaissance and
the New Negro--New Negro
Renaissance. Just
for your understanding,
I'm talking about the
exact same thing. This is
actually old habit. For
the longest time when I was
being trained and educated,
if--and we talked about the
era, it's always about the
Harlem Renaissance. In the
last twenty
years or so, that,
well probably a
little more than that,
but the--the use of Harlem
Renaissance has faded in
many quarters, with the
reference to New--to the New
Negro Renaissance as well.
And I--I should be detailing
some of that in today's
lecture. But for me,
this is
just--it's old habit,
but with a recognition
of a much more common,
and I think accurate,
depiction of how you'd
understand this era,
and that is the--as,
excuse me, the New Negro
Renaissance. Whatever I'm
going to call it
in this lecture,
I want you to think of
the Renaissance as a moment
where issues of
culture, where politics,
where economics,
where social psychology,
and perhaps even social
pathology--not even perhaps,
certainly social pathology,
come crashing together.
Collectively,
these things, culture,
politics, economics, social
psychology and pathology,
collectively forging a human
creed out of a human need.
In the time that remains,
I'm going to canvass the
Renaissance, hitting some
of the famous high spots,
calling your attention to
some lesser known moments,
and suggesting some
alternative ways to think
about what the
Renaissance actually is.
Let's go back to Countee
Cullen's "Heritage." This
is seen as one of the
hallmark poems of the
Renaissance. If you come
across some selections of
Cullen's poetry
and anthologies,
you'll be sure to see this
poem cited. But there's
another poem called,
also called "Heritage" that
preceded Cullen's. It was
written by an artist named
Gwendolyn Bennett.
Renaissance historians don't
really have much to
say about Bennett.
Much of her
work, her paintings,
her sculpture, her writings,
much of the work was
destroyed by an angry
father and stepmother,
who wanted her to do
something "useful" with her
life. But it's worth
pausing for a moment to
reflect on her work, and to
think about the fact that
what we--and, and to think
about the fact that what we
see here, read,
about the Renaissance,
has far too little to do
with the women artists
during the period. There
were a lot of them doing
important work.
Anyway, "Heritage" by
Gwendolyn Bennett. It's a
much shorter poem
but, well you'll see,
you'll see why I read it.
"I want to see the
slim palm-trees,
Pulling at the clouds, With
little pointed fingers...
I want to see lithe Negro
girls, Etched dark against
the sky, While sunset lingers.
I want to hear
the silent sands,
Singing to the moon, Before
the Sphinx-still face...
I want to hear the chanting
Around a heathen fire
Of a strange black race.
I want to breathe
the Lotus flow'r,
Sighing to the stars
With tendrils drinking
at the Nile...
I want to feel the surging
Of my sad people's soul,
Hidden by a minstrel-smile."
Like Cullen--and this is--I
mean Cullen's poem is quite
famous; this one is sort
of an afterthought. Like
Cullen, Bennett has a highly
romanticized notion of what
one would find in
Africa. Also like Cullen,
Bennett has an angry coda in
her poem that recognizes the
painful side of heritage
as well. Africa has exotic
strength,
natural beauty, grace,
but it's also been seen as
the birthplace of a people
who have to hide their pain
behind a "minstrel-smile."
So if taking these
two poems together,
black America's heritage
presents such a quandary.
What are we to make of
the New Negro Renaissance?
There are at least two
critical things to know
about the Renaissance, at
least for the purposes of
this class and the
examinations. It needs to
be thought of as a movement,
and it needs to be thought
of as a movement of
binaries. And I'll be
getting to that in a
moment. I'll be getting
to--I mean, you might want
to take the notes down.
I'll be talking a bit about
the binaries in a moment,
but these are the binaries
that I--that I think are
worth thinking about. Now
what makes it a movement?
As I said at the
beginning of the lecture,
it has no singular
leader like Garvey,
or Du Bois, or
Father Divine,
or Booker T.
Washington.
But I think we could
consider it a movement,
because to
understand the Renaissance,
one has to understand a
broad range of things that,
taken together, have
coherence. It's a movement
involve--that involves
the written word. It's a
movement that involves the
theater. It's a movement
that involves music. It's a
movement that involves the
material arts, sculpture and
painting. It's a movement
that involves film. It's a
movement that involves club
life, as you see detailed in
this--this very intense book
I've asked you to read
this week. And it's also a
movement of white
infatuation. Now as I said,
and I'll start--I'll start
detailing these in a moment,
it's also a
movement of binaries,
they're on the screen
there. It's American and
it's African. It's urban
and it's rural. It embraces
high culture and low, or
folk culture. It's about
racial independence and
about patronage. So the
Renaissance is this moment
of astonishing cultural
production going in
many different directions,
expressed in many
different ways,
but it grows out of certain
real demographic changes,
political changes, social,
psychological changes as
well. Very simply, the
migration grows out of--I
mean, excuse me, the
Renaissance grows out of the
Great Migration.
You can't have the
Renaissance really without
the migration.
Now remember, the migration
was not literally from a
field in Alabama to New
York City--New York City's
Harlem, although some
certainly did make that
journey in that way. The
migration was moving in fits
and starts,
forward and back,
backward and forwards,
North to South again,
a little further north,
maybe to Midwest to North.
It's a movement of, sort of
a general level of chaos but
tending and trending
towards the North and urban
centers. That soup of
the migration is rather
important because if you are
from the fields in Alabama
and find yourself six months
later--say you've been
picking cotton in Alabama
and now you're working in a,
in a coal field--a coal mine
in West Virginia and you're
there for another year, it's
not just about your labor,
but it's about a kind
of cultural exchange,
your ways of
looking at the world,
the kind of foods you eat
and the way you prepare
them, the songs that are
important to you. There is,
with this migration, a
profound cultural sharing of
experiences, just by
happenstance. When you move
people, their ideas and
their values move with them,
and they clash or they
mix, depending on the
circumstance, in generative
ways. So the Renaissance
develops out of the fact
that the culture is moving
with the people to different
places. And when you have
such an intense change
in places like Chicago,
or Detroit, or New York City
in terms of demographics,
there's a
heightened sense of,
of, of cultural tension,
and that's what's really so
important about the
Renaissance's connection to
the migration, and why
Harlem is often thought of
as the, as the, as
the--referred to as the
Harlem Renaissance, because
Harlem does become the focal
point for so much of
these artistic changes,
although they are happening
everywhere. The Renaissance
develops out of
World War I injustices,
and soldiers returning home,
and the heightened racial
awareness that grows out
of it. I ended last week's
lecture with
Countee Cullen's,
you know, "If We Must
Die," often seen as,
sort of, one of
the, the, the,
the call to arms in a sense,
for the Harlem Renaissance
poets, in retrospect. The
Renaissance develops out of
an intense black political
impatience. I'll explain
more about that in a
moment. It's--It would be
nowhere, the Renaissance,
without patronage,
and it wouldn't--and it
wouldn't be nearly what it
was if you didn't have
technological developments,
in terms of the
publication--publishing
industry and
entertainment industry,
literally, how you
produce records,
mass marketing. The
Renaissance wouldn't have
spread as broadly as it
did without these changes as
well. So there's some
technical aspects to it.
Now let me try to narrow
things down a little bit on
the Renaissance
itself. You know,
it involves these
different things,
these different kinds of
artistic expressions. It
involves the
different forces,
you know sort of combined in
a such a way to make such an
important
moment, but, you know,
what are its boundaries?
The Renaissance--I mean the
short answer is, we don't
really know. We kind of
generally agree, we being
people who agree with me.
The--But most historians
really point to the
Renaissance starting in
1919. There are certainly
moments here and
there where you,
you know, have artists
coming together doing some
bold and interesting things
prior to that. There's no
doubt about it.
But in terms of a
self-consciousness, a
collective self-conscious,
a will to change, it's when
the black soldiers return
home. It's when the cities
go up in flames and black
communities are targeted,
and it's given to Countee
Cullen publishing
this really spectacular
poem--excuse
me, Claude McKay,
publishing "If We Must
Die." And if I said
earlier--mental rewind--if I
said Countee Cullen with "If
We Must Die," it
is Claude McKay,
just to make sure I
didn't misspeak. Now that
beginning, so
we'll, you know,
we'll stick with 1919 for
this course. This is a
pretty accepted start point
for the Harlem Renaissance,
New Negro Renaissance.
Its endpoint is really much
murkier. Many will point
to the stock market crash in
1929, and there's
compelling reasons,
because once
disposable income dries up,
it's much harder to
patronize a club or support
an artist. So if the
Renaissance continues after
1929, it's certainly
diminished. But if you stop
it at 1929, you would
actually cut out from the
Harlem Renaissance
conversation a lot of its
most famous artists and
writers whose work really
comes to be known in the
1930s. So 1929 is a bit
harsh of a cut off. We
can move it into the 1930s
easily, with the growth of
the federal government and
the New Deal and the--and
the support the New Deal
gives to artists of all
colors and backgrounds. And
you might even carry it
up to 1941 when the U.S.
enters the Second World
War. This might even be
stretching it a little bit.
A few people even say the
Renaissance never ended; it
just kind of quieted down.
I think for our purposes,
to have it--a useful
understanding of
the Renaissance,
we really need to think
of it as an inter-war
phenomenon, 1919 to
certainly the early 1930s,
with less clarity maybe to
1941. The endpoint is less
important to me. Now within
this vague realm of the
timeline, there is an
important marker that
there's no debating: 1925 is
universally recognized as a
pivotal moment in the
history of the Renaissance.
Maybe it began with
Claude McKay's poem,
but a pivotal moment is
the 1925 publication of a
journal, a special issue
of a journal called Survey
Graphic. It was
edited, this special issue,
edited by this
man, Alain Locke,
a professor of philosophy at
Howard University. People
recognized--Locke was one of
these people--that there was
something happening in terms
of cultural production.
There were a
lot of, you know,
art shows, a lot
of new music forms,
a rise in popularity and
certainly consumption. He
goes, you know,
"I want to tap,
I want to gather
up this moment,
as we can do it in a
journal" and so he gathers a
collection of poems,
excerpts from plays,
essays, and short stories,
that represented in Locke's
mind the new spirit in
black America. The special
edition of Survey Graphic
is published as a book.
It's expanded and
published as a book,
edited by Locke, that is
recognized as the bible of
the Renaissance, and
that book is called The New
Negro.
Now you remember the, the
phrase New Negro goes back
to Booker T.
Washington's, you know,
popularizing of it at the
turn of the century.
It becomes more commonplace
with this changing
mentality.
Soldiers come home,
World War I, and really
starts to go through the
culture with Alain Locke's
publication of the New Negro
in 1926. The journal
becomes--a special issue of
the journal becomes an
expanded book. I mentioned
earlier that one of the
things you need to think
about the--the Renaissance
is thinking of it as a
movement, a movement
engaging politics. Locke,
a philosopher, was
convinced that culture,
that thing he's trying to
gather up in the book New
Negro¸ culture was a
political battleground. He
was explicit on these
terms--this issue. The
Renaissance in Locke's
term, in Locke's opinion,
was all about a fight for
cultural recognition. And
then once that
recognition was gained,
it was about political
freedom and equality. That
once black Americans could
demonstrate that they have
something to--something to
contribute to the world from
a cultural standpoint,
others would have no choice
but to recognize that
they had something of value,
and they would be embraced
and given their political
freedom of full equal
rights. You can hear this
in the opening and
closing quotes from Locke's
introduction to the
book, The New Negro.
On the New Negro
mentality, Locke says,
"For the younger generation
is vibrant with a new
psychology; the new spirit
is awake in the masses,
and under the very eyes of
the professional observers
is transforming what has
been a perennial problem
into the progressive phases
of contemporary Negro life."
On the value of culture
to political possibility,
Locke says the following:
"It must be increasingly
recognized that the
Negro has already made very
substantial contributions,
not only in his folk-art
music especially--not
only in his folk-art,
music especially, which has
always found appreciation,
but in larger,
though humbler and less
acknowledged ways.
...
A second crop of the Negro's
gifts promises still more
largely.
He now becomes a conscious
contributor and lays aside
the status of beneficiary
and ward for that of a
collaborator and participant
in American civilization.
...
The especially cultural
recognition they win should
in turn prove the key to
that revaluation of the
Negro which must precede or
accompany any considerable
further betterment of
race relationships."
Culture is the key for
Locke. So Locke really,
I mean literally saw the
Renaissance as a political
movement, shrouded in the
cloth of culture. Locke
talks as some length about
the folk culture that so
often defined, for
good or for bad,
black life in America.
And to be sure, this is part
of the heritage that many
Renaissance artists hailed
in their work. But the
celebration of
folk art styles,
rhythms, and voices becomes
very complicated when we
consider white infatuation,
or where scholars will often
use the phrase, the "white
gaze." "The white gaze."
What do we mean by the
white gaze? Talking about,
literally in some ways, the
people who come to Harlem
clubs to witness
and experience the,
quote, "delirious" social
scene in Harlem. White
patrons coming to clubs,
clubs where blacks are
performing in Harlem, that
blacks could not go into as
patrons themselves. Now
that's a literal. He's
talking about white bodies
buying tickets to see black
performances.
But less literally,
the gaze I'm talking about
described white patrons'
fascination, not just with
black cultural performance,
but cultural ability. You
have prominent patrons like
Albert Barnes, the
famous art collector,
a white man who
praised blacks',
quote, "authentic and native
talent." And these are very
loaded words. You
know, what is authentic,
after all?
What do you mean
when you say native?
What kind of baggage is
being carried with that?
Now Barnes was recognized as
a great patron of the arts
and as a great, as the
phrase was of the time,
"a friend of the
race." No one doubted,
you know, his credentials
in that regard. And Locke,
Locke recognized this and
wanted to have Barnes in his
collection. He's
an important figure,
playing an important role in
the cultural development or
the propagation of African
American cultural skills.
So Barnes has the second
essay in The New Negro. And
he says the following: "That
there should have developed
a distinctively Negro art
in America was natural and
inevitable.
A primitive race,
transported into an
Anglo-Saxon environment and
held in subjection to that
fundamentally--fundamentally
alien influence,
was bound to undergo the
soul stirring experiences
which always find their
expression in great art.
...
The most important element
to be considered is the
psychological complexion of
the Negro as he inherited it
from his primitive ancestors
and which he maintains to
this day.
The outstanding
characteristics are his
tremendous
emotional endowment,
his luxuriant and free
imagination and a truly
great power of
individual expression.
He has in superlative
measure that fire and light
which, coming from within,
bathes his whole world,
colors his images and
impels him to expression.
The Negro is a
poet by birth.
...
The white man in the mass
cannot compete with the
Negro in
spiritual endowment.
Many centuries of
civilization have attenuated
his original gifts and have
made his mind dominate his
spirit."
Now I know I've talked about
civilization and civilizing
ideologies some--you know, a
lot to date in this course.
But one reason I
share this quote,
because it is--it is the,
the currency that a lot of
these--these black leaders
and white leaders share in
terms of really
who is to be saved,
who is to be fought for,
who has certain gifts. And
Barnes, as dated as this
language sounds today,
and even condescending, he
was being quite clear in his
admiration of blacks'
cultural gifts. Now he also
thought that that's because
they were really not quite
fully civilized, but they
were in touch with something
more primal than whites.
Whites no longer--they used
to have it. They could no
longer be in touch with this
part of their spirit because
their minds had become
overdeveloped. Now
fascination with--pardon me
one second here. The--the
fascination from the
patrons' standpoint would be
complicated in the sense of
Albert Barnes, an incredibly
important art collector,
supporter of the arts and
black artistic production,
but with these sort of
interesting world views.
You have other patrons
like Charlotte Mason who,
rather wealthy and supported
the artists in a different
way than Barnes.
Barnes would buy their
art; Charlotte Mason,
you know, had
artists on retainer,
most famously Zora
Neale Hurston and,
at one point, Langston
Hughes as well. And Zora
Neale Hurston, whose most
famous work comes out a
little bit later in the
1930s--this is sort of the
issue of stretching
the Renaissance a bit.
Essentially,
Charlotte Mason would,
you know, give Zora Neale
Hurston a place--have Zora
Neale Hurston stay
in her apartment,
and then would give her
assignments. Zora Neale
Hurston, training as
an anthropologist,
and Mason would send her
down South to go and explore
an area, and then come back
and "tell me stories" about
this native
folk in, you know,
the backwaters of Georgia.
Now--and Hurston would do
this. I mean she didn't
have any other resources,
but there were times when
she would push back against
the patron who insisted on
being called "Godmother."
She pushed back
saying, you know,
"I don't want to do this. I
want to do something else."
And Mason said, "Well, I
want you to do what I asked
you to do." So this
patronage thing becomes very
complicated, especially when
you consider that Mason also
was asking Hurston to be
her housekeeper at the same
time. Langston Hughes was
under Mason's umbrella until
he got in a
fight--Langston Hughes,
incredibly--sort of
the poet laureate of the
Renaissance--got in a huge
fight with Mason and with
Hurston and was sort of
cut off essentially. So
patronage was complicated
in terms that are quite
literal, in terms of "I'm no
longer going to put food on
the table for you," or "I'm
going to kick you out of my
apartment." Patronage could
be complicated in other ways
also, and this is actually a
local story. It turns out
that if you want to study
the Harlem Renaissance,
the best place in the world
to do so is a few blocks
away at the Beinecke. It
has the largest collection
of African
American literature,
arts, sculpture, and
paintings for this period.
The other great repository
is down in New York City,
the Schomburg
Research Center,
but for the Renaissance, you
need to come to Yale. Carl
Van Vechten,
white writer, artist,
photographer, and a great
supporter of the arts in New
York City in sort
of salon culture,
really connected a lot of
black artists and white
artists together, and a lot
of black artists and white
patrons together.
And he
convinced his friends,
his black artist
friends, you know,
"Why don't you give your
papers or your collections
to Yale when it's time?"
And then he convinced a lot
of his white artist friends
to give their stuff to Fisk
University,
historically black college,
when it was their time.
The thinking was that black
scholars would study black
artists and vice versa,
and they would have to go to
these other institutions and
sort of cross-pollinate
in some sort of way.
I mean--and there's actually
a lot of truth in what Van
Vechten set up
as a, as a model.
It's also rather funny the
way that--that libraries,
you know, have
this--this coding.
You all know that, you
know, you'll find U.S.
History in E185
point whatever. Well,
in the Beinecke, a lot of
their holdings are--I think
Z is the beginning
of, of, you know,
rare books collection--ZA
blank. And for the James
Weldon Johnson collection,
which is the umbrella for
the, the works that Van
Vechten got brought over to
Yale, it's ZAN for
"Negro." I mean,
it's just this--it's just
the way things get coded. I
mean this is our culture
in which we live. Anyway,
Carl Van Vechten was
responsible for having
created at Yale an amazing
repository of black arts.
He's also responsible for
writing a very controversial
book. And this is
not super high quality,
but a copy of its
cover, Negro--Nigger Heaven,
a book that a lot of
other black leaders were,
were horrified that he
would turn on the race in a
sense. But some are saying,
well--it's about Harlem.
It's about the Renaissance,
and it's about the--it's
really not--shall we say,
it's a clumsy book. It's
very overwrought and
dramatic. It's about,
you know, the mysterious
beat of the tom-tom,
and, you know, the, the
whirling dancers and all
these sort of things, highly
romanticized. You can see
here, you know, highly
stylized African material
forms as well. Some black
leaders thought this was,
you know, spot on,
exactly right. Others,
most, were actually
horrified that Van Vechten
would publish a
book like this,
certainly with this title.
So patronage coming in
different forms
was, was complicated,
just flat out complicated.
And that's partly what Scene
of Harlem Cabaret you're
reading for this week is
getting at. Now I
mentioned earlier,
we need to think of the
Renaissance as a movement,
and one that
involved white fascination,
and also as a movement of
binaries that combined,
a movement that combined
in one space seeming
opposites. The most
important binary in this
regard is America and
Africa. That Africa was
being hailed and celebrated
at all was revolutionary.
And I don't want to
dismiss this point of the
Renaissance, because it's
really quite important.
That Africa, the lands--the
land mass and its people,
was being interpreted as
contributing something
worthwhile to civilization
was a radical break. And
one can see this often in
the famous work by Aaron
Douglas, who
actually did this cover,
but also produced a lot
of other art from the
Renaissance--that is
recognized as some of the
most important
paintings, visual art,
from the Renaissance. And
you see in Douglas an artist
doing sort of the heavy
lifting of bringing African
cultural styles, you
know, starkly angular,
and bringing them into an
American narr--narration,
into an American scene. And
we can see this really in
several murals that he--it's
a six-panel mural that's at
the Schomburg Research
Center in New York City.
And there's
several of--these are,
you know, they're
actually bigger than this,
large-scale paintings, that
tell a story of the African
diaspora to the United
States and what this
diaspora involves.
In--and I'll show you four
of these panels. In the
first, you have "The
Negro in an African Setting,
an exhortation of the
culturally vibrant African
past, with the ring shout
religious tradition being
practiced and drums, dances
in the state of ecstasy.
And you'll see in these
images I'm going to show you
here themes of,
well-stylized forms,
but also circles and light.
That's what ties the images,
the paintings, together.
You have the arrival of the
ships in this painting,
Africans now in shackles,
not knowing what
their future possesses,
holds for them. Ships
coming to see them. You
have a beam of light
coming in from the distance,
as you'll see, sort of
forming a triangle you'll
see in other images.
You see it again right away
here. Now you have an ideal
of the Deep South. We see
echoes of the African past,
certainly in the body forms
and shapes. We also see,
right--going from
right--from your right to
your left,
expressions of hard labor,
of celebration
in the circle,
again, invoking
the, the ring circle,
playing African--instruments
with African roots like the
banjo, but also playing the
guitar. The movement heads
you from right to left,
and you see in the distance,
to the left, the North
Star. This is that beam of
light cutting through, the
North Star as a path toward
freedom. What you
also see though,
and I can't reach it.
I'll use the mouse to
get up there. Up here,
right here, see somebody
hung and a lynch rope coming
down. So the ideal of the
deep South is hard work,
cultural
celebration, tragedy,
horrific tragedy, and a
future elsewhere. And what
was elsewhere? The promised
land. Shackles are broken
right here. The Civil War
is mentioned visually. The
promised land, the land of
factories in the future.
You have in these
images--and I've gone
through very quickly,
looking at my time--the
binaries of,
you know, African
primitive--prim--primitivened
ss--that can't be the right
word. Civilized,
organized, North,
freedom, industrial. The
tragedies and the triumphs
involved in the migration
from one place to another.
You also have in--and
that's in the visual arts,
in one sort of expressive
moment--you have this
binary, this wrestling with
the African-ness and the
American-ness in
poetry as well. I mean,
you've heard some of the
messier versions in Countee
Cullen's heritage. Langston
Hughes the--again one of the
most famous artists of
prose in the Renaissance,
writes the poem, "Negro
Speaks of Rivers." It's
often hailed as sort of one
of the great documents of
the Renaissance.
Langston
Hughes: The poem is,
The Negro Speaks of Rivers.
It was written when I was 18
years old...
Professor Jonathan
Holloway: No pressure.
Langston Hughes: ...just
out of high school.
It goes like this.
"I've known rivers: I've
known rivers ancient as the
world and older than the
flow of human blood in human
veins. My soul has
grown deep like the rivers.
I bathed in the Euphrates
when dawns were young.
I built my hut near the Congo
and it lulled me to sleep.
I looked upon the Nile and
raised the pyramids above it.
I heard the singing of the
Mississippi when Abe Lincoln
went down to New Orleans, and
I've seen its muddy bosom turn
all golden in the sunset.
I've known rivers:
Ancient, dusky rivers.
My soul has grown deep
like the rivers."
I don't think we need to
spend much time interpreting
this poem, but
it is seen as,
again, one of these great
documents that ties together
a lot of the different
strands of the Renaissance.
Hughes is talking about the
great rivers of the world,
and he's also talking about
places where there were
ancient civilizations. And
he's connecting these great
rivers with ancient
civilizations that were
black African
civilizations. And he's
saying, sort of,
deep in my blood,
I've known them all, I,
sort of the black man,
the black individual, knows
them all. "My soul has
grown deep like the
rivers." So there is in the
Renaissance a harkening back
to an ancient time and a
place. Even in this
poem's simplicity,
we see this
harkening back and this,
this reaching for something
of value in a civilized
past. Now this reaching
back to an African past,
although remarkable for
even the fact of celebrating
anything African, was not
without controversy. A
figure named
George Schuyler,
popular syndicated
column--columnist and author
who becomes--who's a
gadfly sort of and becomes
incredibly conservative over
the next thirty or forty
years. He's un--politically
unpredictable at this
point. He writes an essay
called "The Negro Art Hokum"
in the Nation, the magazine
called the Nation. And he
says that Negro
Americans, his words,
were "little more
than lamp--lamp blacked
Anglo-Saxons;" that the
best black artists merely
imitated white style, highly
stylized European style,
and failed to demonstrate
their own. That any black
art worth knowing
was really--you know,
a white artist would
have done the same thing,
but maybe with a black
subject. A week later,
Langston Hughes, who you
just heard him reading his
own poem, responds with
a very famous document,
"The Negro Artist and the
Racial Mountain." This is
in your reading of course.
Seen as also another central
text of the era.
And he says in that piece
it's the duty of the black
artist to reach back, to
sort of speak of rivers,
if you will, and develop the
culture that defined their
life, be it African, rural,
or southern. Blacks had to
make--had to make a
claim, according to Hughes,
had to make a claim on
their own blackness,
articulated it in
their own terms,
and in their own ways.
They were not lamp-blacked
Anglo-Saxons. They
were their own being. But
articulating blackness
could mean different things,
of course. Even if one
distanced himself or herself
from the highly
stylized African past,
something that's often
seen in sort of these
condescending ways, like
through people like Carl Van
Vechten with his, you know,
mysterious tom-tom and such,
were black Americans,
if they're not African,
well, are they southern?
What does it mean to be
southern? Are they rural?
rural? These are some
of these early things I
mentioned at the beginning
of the lecture about what
the Renaissance was. It
was pulling from all these
different kinds of lived
experiences and imagined
experiences, but never
without controversy. Black
leaders were angry at
Langston Hughes and Zora
Neale Hurston. And if you
remember back a week or so,
with Sterling Brown even,
for writing in dialect,
for using folk dialect. So
many black leaders and other
black artists
are saying, "Look,
we're not going to be
respected if we start,
you know, talking like 'the
folk.' We don't want to
celebrate that. We want
to celebrate these highly
stylized forms." So what do
you get? You get profoundly
mixed messages about what is
valued and what is valuable
during this era.
Revealing block--excuse me,
black folk dialect was
counterproductive to the
political project that
Du Bois-- that Locke
envisioned, of demonstrating
black excellence. Just hang
on with me a couple more
minutes here. The desire to
move away from the rural
folk experience was also
accompanied by a heightened
sense of blacks as exotic.
The white gaze in the U.S.
and abroad made superstars
out of performers like
Josephine Baker, who in
the--this publicity still
you see here, one of her
most famous images that was
marketed, famous for her
banana dance. Not getting
any traction in the U.S.,
she goes off to France and
becomes a humongous star in
France. But it makes you
wonder at what
cost, you know,
at what cost did
this conversion come,
harking back to the
beginning of the class?
What was lost when Baker
develops her power and her
international fame when
she dons the banana skirt,
often topless, as a
native African woman,
using the bananas in her
skirt to entice a sleeping
white explorer?
What's being lost in the
transaction, even though
something really quite
amazing is being gained as
well? Is it a step forward
for one, but a large step
backward of the people? So
the Renaissance is many
competing narratives,
as it would inevitably be
with all these different
people producing arts and
ideas and culture. And then
it begs the question,
because of these competing
narratives, who is the
Renaissance for? Was it for
blacks, was it for whites,
was it for the wealthy,
was it for workers? Was it
just about art and notions
of beauty? Beauty is
a complicated thing.
I'm just going very quickly
here. This is also the era
of celebrating blackness,
celebrating African forms.
But it also, Madam C.J.
Walker becomes the
most powerful black
businesswoman, a
multimillionaire,
by selling hair
straightening products and
skin lightening creams,
idealizing white beauty. I
already showed you this
image earlier that the
Renaissance, the New Negro
mentality is about a certain
kind of anger and political
stance. And then the last
image here, in this
image you start seeing the
Renaissance as being larger
than just the arts. It's
larger than just Harlem.
It's more than just words.
This is a picture
of Fredi Washington,
one of the--one of the
great performers of the
Renaissance, a
dancer, most famously,
and an actress. And she
forms--she joins a group
called the Negro Artists
Guild during this era. You
know and it's no mistaking
the fact that she has
lighter skin and she has
"good hair" as the phrase
would have been, and
actually still is in many
places. But notice her
armband. She's wearing a
protest armband. It's of a
person being lynched. That
there's such
resistance to, you know,
anti-lynching campaigns that
artists were joining these
campaigns through their
own artistic slash political
guilds in this case. So the
Renaissance is all of these
things, in small ways and,
and going in these different
directions, but
taken together,
it is a movement of an
ideology that comes out of a
movement of people that
wrestles with the current
sort of racial
ideologies of the time,
turns them upside down. It
celebrates at the same time
it dismisses and it engages
in the world in terms of
producing new
art in new ways,
but also visiting old
battles in images you see
like here, with Fredi
Washington protesting
lynching and the lack of
anti-lynching laws in the
United States. Thanks for
hanging on a couple more
minutes, and have
fun in the snow.